something that Robinson and car will appreciate
from the drive as the opening face off since it's
Thursday night you guessed it it's brought to you
by DHL supply chain it's picked off and the Flyers
head away CER on that third defensive pairing
clears to Center the jackets on the turnover
again it's rinsky across the line puck gets away
here's a break moving in faraby across given go
and scores Flyers are on the board and it's faraby
on the two on one picking up his first goal to
the young National Hockey League season it's a
little bit of a mismatch you see Zach loses that
puck but forwards are also dipped in and on your
left the defenseman loses his edges so a two on0
break no chance for Elvis M leans whatsoever
and that's sha Couer he's missed 22 months of
hockey he's their number one Center and there he
picks up his first point in the season and it is
a one- nothing Philadelphia lead long stretch
pass knocked down deep in the zone hustling to
it there is good r with a centering pass that's
dropping it there there's a shot High stick side
picked up by marchenko Full Speed Ahead dishes it
out of the wing save at the s h rebound score the
Blue Jackets capitalize on the rebound J Fe taking
the rebound off the ouro shot and we're tied at
one deep in his own end you can see Flyers are
changing he takes advantage sucks everyone up
to the middle of the ice and then Jake Bean the
defenseman all the defenseman are on their toes
here to start this game for the Blue Jackets
fentii shot creates the rebound and there's
Bean on the spot Carter Hart no chance there as
that Rolling Puck and a confusion in front he
just can't pick it up and and the Blue Jackets
are on the board and there are the pantiles and
try to jump when they have an opportunity so
here goes Zach on the puck but other than that
they'll try to let that out outside Zone play
Stay here's Cole singer across the line fires
off the goal post rebound sa goal lights on Wow
but Cole cyinder look at him here he's like I'm
going to have all this ice uncontested and
that's the value of Johnny good draw the
defenseman is anticipating that pass to Johnny
good it doesn't go and neither does that shot
how about goodro he gets the rebound here he
said Mom looked after them I was focusing on
my opening night's performance here's a lead pass
L carries in waits for some reinforcements dishes
ahead quick shot scores that one off the far post
and in and it is connecting with his first of the
year after a career-high 31 last season the third
line wing and this is a play in the offensive zone
you can see that drop pass just gone wrong and
the Flyers doing a great job early in this game
at transition and the Blue Jackets want to have
their defenseman up and that causes this confusion
as kky the right-handed shot coming down the
left side because he's not really selling much
and he just muscles on the left wing loton could
not control it the jacket send it out to center
now the puck turned over again here's texier
moves it on the way fires a shot save Carter
H come on Rimer no you know what the Youth of
fanti how about the energy in this opening that
that sequence the that was put on here introducing
the players Jack it's really an effort to get Puck
to The Net Quick about 16 shots the 14 here
walking in oh what a stop Justin dad walks in
after taking a feed kid 19 years old and how about
him off the face off here he stays below the puck
there but he makes a nice play getting open that's
a backhand pass to Danforth you're right beautiful
play by by the young man and then Dan for saw
the top corner but he hit the middle of the net
good peing to the point for stall from the left
wing off the goal post stall again Pat save
M leens we'll be looked at again but those are
the two goals for the Philadelphia Flyers Flyers
coming in off the wing save M lein Rebound with
Elvis down but gathered up alertly there by the
captain Jenner three times five times three
is a player and what a pick up for the Blue
Jackets here you see him always talking to the
players during practice and there passal Vincent
leans on him a lot oh there's a break moving
in Breakaway attempt dened Elvis M leans with
a stick save and let's see if that can't rally
the troops here Liars into Columbus territory
final seconds down to seven and Elvis squeezes
the bads and holds off had a lot of flow within
the preseason but right now they're on their
heels and credit to Philadelphia Flyers they've
got some speed through the neutral zone they're
doing a good job in their own end offer rebounds
and plays as you can see that puck actually
went under the armor Flyers change up a little
more than a minute to go here a scoreless second
period long stretch pass there broken up by the
Flyers K connecting on the right wing deflected
at the side of the net there Elis just watched
that pu bounce away his biggest one as you can
see the Flyers Blue Jackets tried to push that
puck up the ice quickly but there was a little
hesitation there and there Elvis got the blocker
out this is marchenko Kelly suin said and he got
it right look at that marchenko stepped right on
the puck suland let's see if they can get the
offense going interestingly enough just prior
to puck drop Kelly selon going over her and giving
Pascal a uh idea of how he ruled on the two-minute
minor as opposed to a 5-minute major sustaining
injuries 47 different players played at least one
game with Columbus a year ago I to stay away from
that moving right in P Jack oh the puck was kept
out of the net as we go to break an attempt there
save M leans and swept away from the front of the
net by pe [Applause] jenard over off through
a crowd left in the slot and there's Carter
Hart from behind the net around the Dasher lineer
throws it back good R will pick it up Johnny
goodro looks for the seam in a redirect there from
texier who's right on the doorstep here good row
texier lightning can't squeeze it the net is empty
and proov able to knock down the attempted pass
by conning jackets as a result less than two to go
line eight that long stride will backand in Carter
hers out of the net he'll play it off the glass
jackets attempt to knock it down it hops over
the stink of proov and a race for the puck moving
in behind the defense who scores faraby with his
second of the [Music] night Cam ainson excuse me
and is 89 with the empty net goal a massive save
off that Faceoff win just hit Carter Hart and then
cam ainson put that in the back of the net with to
affect people in a positive way any any way he
can with the effort he puts in good for him long
shot blocked in front of Hart Who incidentally
ped picked up an assist on Atkinson's empty neck
goal Maro into the slot scores there's time left
the jackets have cut the deficit to one and it
is Patrick l with his first of the Season just s
when he got this Puck he knew exactly what he was
going to do with it he's had a number of attempts
tonight but right there he always knows what to do
with it but this one hits the net it's a quick
release might have got deflected there as well
trying to protect that P seconds remaining jackets
have got to fire that pu towards the net good roow
behind Jenner Philadelphia send it up and out
reaching for proov here's conect as the horn
goes to end the game and they point to the net
will they allow that goou just as the buzzer went